i don't want a masculine woman no guy
and a lot of guys tolerate this but no
guy really
needs an argumentative woman in his life
you know no that is so true you know so
true who's gonna question his every
decision you know what i mean and he's a
pain in the ass it
is fight it's the time it just stops the
momentum yeah you know you want to you
want to yes sir chick like you know like
we need to go here yes sir let's do it i
prefer it that way i was like don't
[ __ ] ask me where i wanted to eat
where just do you book it and we'll go
like i don't ha like i don't i i want to
be pampered
just
take my hand and said we're going here
thank you that's what i said and do you
say thank you yes i do every time with
your husband listen every time we go out
and eat and he he you know he pays
whatever and i'm like thank you hon for
the food dude my girl same way every
time
yeah my only question with that is
a lot of women say that yeah and then
you take them to the wrong restaurant
that they didn't want to go to it's food
i think you date a lot of shitty women
no i'm not saying it for me do you think
uh pretty people no i don't deal with
high maintenance women no well it seems
like you do because they're complaining
no not at all now we're going to team up
on you oh [ __ ] i
[Laughter]
and i'm more just speaking out of like
there's going to people be like all
right well i took my girl to the sushi
restaurant turns out you hate sushi
whatever i mean who the hell hates sushi
there's rice so you're saying just pick
the [ __ ] restaurant yeah take the
girl there don't ask if she wants to do
that if she'll find something if she
likes you she'll go to mcdonald's yeah
that's the truth she likes you my first
date with my ex
was at a mcdonald's he called me up he
was like hey and we hooked up before
that you want to mcflurry babe yeah he
was like hey i'm just on my way to work
i was going to mcdonald's to get food do
you want to come with i was like sure
and they love that because they love to
just feel oh he wants me to be part of
this if they like the guy by the way i'm
supposed to take a girl to dinner
tonight that [ __ ] just got canceled
we're going to mickey d's
[Laughter]
no i mean the best date ever is like you
know
put put something nice on
i'm gonna pick you up at eight exactly
do you agree with this natalia uh yes i
do you do i do i like the idea of like
someone just because it's like they're
planning an event for you to attend yeah
get ready look your best look pretty
we're going we have reservations at 9 00
p.m i'll see you then that's what i do
with my girl that's what you want yeah
would you say that most women want that
exact conversation yeah because because
i feel like when a dude does that i feel
like he put thought into it it doesn't
matter if it's freaking mcdonald's or
whatever i think he's put he put thought
into it listen i want you to get ready i
want to look at your best you got a
mcflurry coming your way yeah yeah and
maybe a little mcrib
i would want to go to a nice restaurant
maybe a little more
pick up sausage but like if you're
saying hey we're getting dinner like
we're gonna have dinner tonight and it's
like a crappy dinner you know don't tell
me to get dressed and everything i
wouldn't take it the most romantic thing
ever is when a dude cooks for you
that one time he does it because it's
your first date whatever i love cooking
i don't let any man into my kitchen is
like stay the [ __ ] away from my kitchen
do not touch anything don't even look at
me
just sit somewhere else
but when he does it for you as a date
yeah and he you know invites you over
it it doesn't have to be something like
elaborate or i don't know why why is it
a turn on for a man to cook for you
because it's he's putting in effort is
that what it is yeah he's putting in an
effort to the relationship by the way a
gentleman out there if you can't cook
here's the move
okay order it and pour the oven
in the oven
next thing you know oh i think dinner's
out
oh you're cooking or maybe you make a
salad
and then you just you know you know you
keep the lasagna the pasta the steak
yeah just you know what it is
it's romantic yes
i like it i get it when you fit in let
me ask you this yes i think it ties into
security when the man tells you like hey
get ready we're going to go do this this
this because girls just want to show up
and have fun yeah i mean cindy lover
always says when i'm having when i tell
my girl we're going i say listen babe
we're going to wolf gangs you have 20
minutes to get ready do this and that's
it you know she's 20 minutes oh yeah
because we move faster that's all the
time you're giving these japanese women
yeah she's she's pretty she doesn't need
a lot of makeup i don't even think
though it's like just about showing up
and having fun i think like a woman just
is like you know he's planning this
event for he's making time out of his
day planning this after working you know
and like i'm working
for to get to know me to spend time with
me like it's it's a whole like yeah a
little mini
okay it's just the value of making an
effort yeah and putting time into the
relationship if you are as busy as you
know you should be i mean
based on what you're trying to and and
also women have to understand they can't
be [ __ ] about it
don't even if you don't like it even if
you you're not a big fan of sushi or
you're not a big fan of the zoo or
you're not a big fan of whatever just
say thank you and appreciate it
it's not hard you know you don't have to
i don't like this
there's a lot of entitlement that comes
with that don't be entitled he he tried
you know right you can at least say
thank you or be like i really appreciate
you did this for me whatever and next
time you go on a date maybe you'll plan
it you'll be like you know next time i
got you so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]